what I see the film I just immediately
think back to the day that I was you
know sitting sitting in my room just
sitting on my floor waiting waiting for
you know a call any call I mean it was I
mean it would be my aunt and I would get
so mad because I was hoping it would be
somebody else you know what I mean and I
was just the hours that I mean the days
were just so long waiting for this call
and I didn't even know if I was gonna
get one or not and so it's just you know
just that you know anxious constantly
waiting and and I just thinking to
myself whoever gets this job is like
winning the lottery you know like
looking back and like seeing you talk
like that and like being just so
freaking excited I mean first of all
that's hilarious
and I do still remember that like it was
yesterday yeah wow that's so funny I
mean listen that was the reality of it I
guess if I knew anything I knew that it
was a big deal you know I guess after
you go in and you audition and you feel
really good about it you're hoping for
that call if you're even thinking that
you might get it then you feel really
good about what you've done and then
it's like at that point man yeah it was
such a wild experience and I do feel
like I freaking won the lottery with
that whole thing I mean that role was
incredible the writing was amazing the
filmmakers obviously everything about
that whole thing was perfect I don't
know if you know this but this year
marked the 10-year anniversary of True
Grit
oh my god that's crazy yeah December and
years isn't that wild Wow yeah crazy
what do you remember most about that
time in your life it's so weird
there were so many of those moments that
were so pivotal for me obviously as a
young woman and just in my career that
I'll never forget but I think just
overall just being so super eager and I
don't know I just remember myself
running around and running down the
hallways during press junkets and like
getting to wear beautiful clothes and I
had my makeup done and it was just like
such a dream and it was so amazing
because I cried my eyes out the last day
of shooting the movie because I
literally thought the world was like
coming to an end and both Jeff Bridges
and Matt Damon looked at me and they
were like totally kind of like laughing
like kid it's just the beginning meaning
like at that point I was like they were
like we're gonna see so much of you
you're gonna be sick of us and I was
like yeah what do I do tomorrow morning
when I don't have a call time it was
just such an amazing experience and I
had the most amazing people around me
the whole time I'm so yeah do you uh
still keep in touch with them at all
with Jeff for with Matt yeah I will you
know the emails are exchanged and Josh
and I actually don't live too far from
each other so we'll run into each other
every now and then they're amazing those
guys any piece of advice that any of
those guys on that set gave you that you
still to this day hold dear to your
heart oh man yeah I mean there there
were so many I mean just being in their
presence I learned so much and I still
do to this day if my mom said I'll find
myself doing something or another that
reminds me of them and I know that I'm
doing it because I learned it from them
and I guess I couldn't have dreamt of a
better place to start but one thing that
I
I almost want to say all of them told me
on separate occasions was to have fun
and not take life too seriously and and
that's you know something that obviously
is and it's a very simple piece of
advice but it's so true and it's so
important and I think that their point
in saying that was at that point in my
life I'd never been on a on a movie set
like that before I didn't know what was
coming and I guess just just hearing
that and knowing and seeing how much fun
they would have coming to work every
single day doing the best work and and
making the best art they possibly could
after that they go home to their
families they come back and do it all
over again and it was just so amazing to
see how wonderful and kind and positive
and professional they were constantly
and they have fun I will tell you that
looking at where your career has sort of
gone since then what's the biggest thing
that you've learned about yourself since
you set foot on that first set and now
looking at where you're at today what I
loved so much about what I do is I'm
constantly challenged I'm constantly you
know tested my my patience is always
tested my skills are constantly being
tested then I feel like for every time
I'm on a set every time I'm in a studio
anytime I go to do what I do I feel like
it's the first time I feel like the
so much I have to learn there so you
know I had so far to go but I I don't
know I do feel like as I grow I gain
confidence and what I do in my abilities
and I think sometimes like if I could go
back and make that movie now you know
what I mean yeah feel like I don't know
I wouldn't do that I wouldn't want to
because I don't want to touch it but I
think that would really teach me then
what what it is I've learned and all
this time we'd have to talk about some
of your other projects Dickinson season
2 had you guys started filming when
everything sort of got shut down so we
actually finished it
Oh months prior which which is great so
fun I mean just you know that was my
first experience in the TV space and not
much time had gone between the shooting
of season one and two so we kind of
picked up right where we left off and
just I don't know it was just an amazing
you know experience to be able to do
that I didn't feel like I've been I'd
had the chance to do that before so I
have an amazing cast and crew and we
just really went in on season two so I'm
excited to see it what should we look
forward to you about season two I know
there's like new cast members the show's
it's pretty wild there's a lot of twists
and turns there's a lot of unexpected
and there's just a hell of a lot more of
that in season two so I'm excited to see
it all come together myself and yeah I'm
just you know looking forward to a lot
of craziness do you think it'll come out
like on the timeline I was supposed to
come out or is the post-production of it
are there holdups on that end as far as
I'm aware I believe everything's on
track but you know everything changes
daily so you know the date I don't know
an actual official day okay no I do know
obviously they're still in
post-production and there's still some
things being tied up but hopefully it
all stays on track what about an update
to the next fighter verse movie oh I
don't have one but I would like to know
myself oh my god doc film is so good I
have I'm like I'm such a fan of that
comeback that sort of thing was
obviously you don't know what it's gonna
look like you have ideas and you have
people telling you and showing you but
you're like okay yeah cool all these
sketches look awesome but until it like
came to life the way it did I mean
nobody could have described that it was
it
so special but anyway no no update as
far as I know but maybe I should figured
that out what would you like to see you
next first spider-gwen is there anything
that you have in mind
man and not not specifically I think you
know her you know she's capable of the
world so I think those storylines are
almost endless is the female centric
spin-off he talked about it all not that
I know of I mean I am NOT in the know
with these things you know it's funny
because I I feel like this is the time
to like you know figure it all out but I
do think obviously everything it's kind
of been slightly put on hold so there
hasn't been there hasn't been much that
I've heard lately okay would you do a
pitch-perfect for yeah I mean yeah that
that whole that first movie okay I
remember distinctly watching that thing
in the theater and afterwards talking to
my mom being like if there's ever that's
kind of movie I want to make everybody
always ask me what's the kind of it
that's booked that's the one and then
when I heard that there was a sequel and
then yeah to be a part of that as a fan
of the franchise was just shocked I
still can't believe it how do we make
that happen we need a mission can you do
that right Hannah
that's yours that's your job during
quarantine okay
[Music]